thank you very much
my case welcome to today's claire
crosstown fund board meeting
i've got a busy agenda today so let's
make a start
uh first of all damien do you have any
apologies of absence
uh i haven't received any chair
i've been i've received apologies for
absence for councillor dale
okay thank you very much carolyn and joe
there's um jill cullingham
and uh nick holland nick referee's aware
nick's a new
board member but um he's also become a
dad for the second time yesterday
um
okay thank you very much and i guess
let's move on to declarations of
interest
does any member today have any
declarations of interest to disclose
with relation to puny interests
and any other interests in relation to
the points on today
i shall take a silence as a no and move
on to the next point
moving on to minutes from the last
meeting so the minutes were attached to
the
the invite i moved up the minutes or a
true reflection
of last month's meeting any objection
moving on to the record
no second nose chair thank you very much
carolyn
in that case we move swiftly on 2.4 for
the accelerator projects update
carl can you take that one it reels up
okay so as you see in your packs um
we're giving you an update again on the
um accelerated funding projects so
anybody who's new to the
boards we were giving um 500k to
accelerate
um projects within the turn investment
plan
and we've um we've started that work
already so there's the relocation
attendance from the bridge street depot
so the the projects is around that is
around the depot is to clear that
site which has now been done so it's
created a 1.2 acre
development platform uh we're looking
um options appraisal has been carried
out and there's three options that have
been
considered at this point and then a
preferred option will be going forward
for outline planning
application may slash june so that's
that's a real success
then we have the demolition of the
former junior school
and as you may recall and there was an
issue with the ecology window because
the funding was really tight in terms of
the timings for that being allocated and
then the ecology stuff that we had to do
because there's
bats within there so and that's been
deferred
and but that work again the surveys that
we need to carry out will be able to
open again i believe it's in may
and and the north east africa district
councils the states department
and derbyshire county councils estate
department are working together to
sort out the um the demolition and all
the rest so that program
is due to start um i believe on site in
august
and then completed by october
and we had a public arts program which
um
is going to be a separate item on the
agenda so i'm going to talk a lot about
that but it's been quite successful and
quite exciting and
junction arts and the artists are going
to go to a lot more detail in that
um then there's also the purchase of the
full constabulary building
um again this is a dcco building but
it's really important in town investment
plan in terms of that creative space
so our estate department and the archery
county councils is the state department
have been working quite closely and
would at this point working out how
would do the valuation
um and then we'll once we've done that
evaluation we'll then look to do the
purchase and then obviously that
building will be
available then for that and that's that
space
later on in the television plan so it's
quite a significant part of the plan
and what we were conscious of with um
that is we've got 500
000 pounds and we wanted to be sure that
if there's any underspent
that we had something ready to
potentially come forward
and because sort of things ever flow and
also that it might be that
and the costs that we initially put in
um were over
actually the reality is so we've started
to look at the
um there's a former snooker club on
broadly's which has been vacant and used
for a number of years
and it is in danger falling to disrepair
and it is very much in the heart of the
playground town deal um
area and for those of you who aren't
sure of it it's next to the
mark's court um accommodation
within northeast africa district
council's ownership so we've lined that
up as a potential um use for if
if there is any underspend on the 500k
we've had evaluation carried out
and we've had successful dialogue with
the uh former trustees while the
current trustees of the club there's two
there's one who lives in clay cross and
there's another one who lives abroad
so that makes it slightly more
challenging but they are interested in
willing and talking to us
so at this point all the accelerated
projects are progressing well
and are on programming exactly where we
expect them to be
and we've started planning for you know
if there is an underspend
that we have something that we can put
into that program to make sure we spend
that full
um 500k that's been allocated to us
so that's that's the update yeah so the
recommendation is for board members to
know the positive progress made on all
the accelerated projects
very much is there any questions to call
yes could i ask a question please i'm
just trying to get the video
um to cooperate but yes hopefully you
can hear me
um yes through the chair um
the probably the most visible uh
constructed
uh accelerated project will be the
former constabulary building
do we have a sort of and i know you're
still in negotiations on the valuation
but do you have a sort of target date as
to when we might
be able to see some actual progress into
bringing this into the creative projects
element of it because i see this as this
is probably the sort of the
flagship this is like the the starting
point is
not the regeneration really
and and i just wondered whether what
sort of timing
we were we were trying to aim for okay
so we we want to agree the valuation
um documents because we're going to go
out to
to get that valued independently so
we're agreeing that with
the spec we're between ourselves and bcc
hopefully by the end of next week
and then we'll be looking to go out and
get that evaluation what we've agreed
with darshan council is that
they still need to to use our building
for the countryside service
at this point and um they are looking to
rationalize their um
their space and at some point um the
countryside service will move out there
what we've said to them is uh we don't
need vacant recession possession of the
property so we would purchase
property and then lease it back to them
on almost a peppercorn rent
and they would have the maintenance and
repair liability for that building
whilst we build up the business case
because we can't do anything until a
business case has been
developed locally assured and then
submitted to government and approved and
then we can start destroying
funding so we've got a year to as you
know to do the business case development
so we can say that at least it's going
to be a year
um so you know minimum a year
potentially 18 months on on
the phasing and when this this part of
the project comes forward
yeah thank you melanie
yes morning everyone just to say that um
with regards your accelerated fund
projects
that um you will be expected to report
progress on them
through a monitoring and evaluation
return in december this year
so obviously the sort of information
that you're gathering now will help sort
of populate that report
okay
yes question from anthony walker tony
walker uh yeah it's a question for carl
really with reference to the
bridge street depot and you've just
mentioned that it's a 1.2 acre site
is that being offered to any of the
businesses that's going to be relocated
from clay cross with them all being in
that local vicinity
at this point um we're looking at the
options in terms of what we do with that
and site so no decisions have been made
around
um end use let alone who would be as a
planner occupy it
but we are conscious that the businesses
that and potentially
may mean maintenance move as well to
progress the television plan
are going to need a location so that is
something that we are
um considering okay
thank you any other questions
you're not saying in your hands so we
can move on to point
five or point four yeah sorry uh the art
project update so
jane are you with us yeah
like hand over to you please okay thank
you who
could whoever's um hosting the meeting
share the screen with me please
um yes i can allow you to share your
screen if that's um that's what i mean
yeah yes i've sorted oh okay
this all should all be sorted sorry
okay can everybody see that okay
nice colorful screen um so thank you
carl um i'm jane wells i work for
junction
arts we're a charity based in
chesterfield
and i'm managing the clay cross
community
engagement and public art project
we've got the rest of the artists team
at the meeting so i'll just quickly
introduce them
there's lucy maycock who has been
delivering the community engagement
workshops
and simon hollingworth will lindley and
andy johnson smith from a different
light collective
who are creating the projection and
overseeing all things technical relating
to the
the projections so you'll know from
the monthly updates that all of the
community engagement workshops have been
successfully delivered
and the purpose of those was to work
with
local people to explore the town
investment plan
and to get their views
so lucy has been working with pupils
from charlie park community primary
school
students foundation art and design
students from chesterfield college
and residents of the old vicarage care
home
lucy's worked with 70 people
she's delivered 19 workshops
and 95 pieces of artwork have been
created
and these um this artwork will inspire
um and form the content for the digital
projections
but in addition to the workshops which
have all been delivered
um remotely of course
lucy's also made up 20 art packs which
have been distributed
through a local food bank to engage even
more people with the project
so the project should have finished now
it should have finished on the 31st of
march
but because of the lockdown restrictions
we've had to
reschedule the projections until
september when the clocks have gone back
and the nights are darker again so from
the
22nd to the 25th of september
people can come down to market street
and see the projections
on the ventilation shaft there
so will lindley has been
working on the content for the
projections
um and
so those screening sorry those
screenings will take place as i said on
the 25th
26th 25th of september with a finale
event
on the 25th that will include
well it's still in the planning stages
but we're hoping it will include
a road closure to enable a larger and
safer place for the activity
it'll be a small scale event to
celebrate and bring
the project to a close and will include
some arts workshops some street
performers
maybe the opportunity to play a digital
game on the old police station we've
been talking to dcc about using
that building um and of course it will
include the projections which will be
the highlight um
just to make the most of the summer
months we want to
keep the profile of the project
sort of high in the sort of public
mind we're creating an exhibition
that will tour local venues um including
places like the library
northeast derbyshire district council
offices
chesterfield college some of the shops
in the town
and also the old methodist church
i think it is next to the police station
um
yes i think that wouldn't nearly there
now so the exhibition will include
a short film about the project
and that film is still being made but
if we've got time it's only three and a
half minutes we'd like to
share the film with everybody
is that okay
yes we have time yeah so
i think it will is will could the screen
be shared with
um will lindley now please
uh oh but this person should be able to
share the screen but you'll have to
you'll need to stop sharing first
oh sorry
okay we'll have you oh yeah i'm psychic
control
great thanks jane um i'm gonna try and
share the screen and the sound
um and as jane has said this is still a
work in progress
um so there's still quite a bit of
tweaking to do
and um on the sound as well but um
hopefully it'll be an indication of what
what's coming so i'll try that now
computer sound
can we all see this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
get you
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
more
[Music]
[Music]
uh okay that's it from us is
any if anybody's got any questions we'd
be happy to
take them
any questions for the digital artist
team
yes carolyn that wasn't a question just
that
yeah i've been enjoyed looking at some
of i've seen some of those images before
uh i love some of the some of the
artwork i've seen absolutely love the
ventilation chef light shows i think
that's
um they look stunning so i'm really
looking forward
to september and uh thanks so much and
well done
thank you melanie did you have a
point you've got your hand raised there
yeah again i just wanted to echo what
carolyn said and i
do think that the you know the light
show is going to be spectacular i'm sure
just one of the things i don't know
whether it's something that you consider
doing but
the towns from delivery partnership are
do i've got like a
our town storytelling um sort of
promotion that they're doing where
they're
they're trying to tell stories about
what's happening in towns and the impact
that's being made
and they're also encouraging you to come
forward with your stories and i just
think that this
proposal the work that you've done and
still you know
still hasn't happened yet would be a
fantastic thing to get them to showcase
so i'll i'll i'll speak to the lady
who's sort of
running that sort of um element of their
support
um but and and shared some links with
you but i think
i i want to promote that as well but i
think it would be helpful if you did
that as a town deal board as well
to contact that that those links so i
will send them to you so i just think
it'd be really helpful
yeah really good thank you
if we have no more questions i don't see
anybody with a hands up so i'll move
forward to
point five we have some new board
members uh carl would you like to
proceed
yeah thank you and as as you know we
completed a recruitment drive for some
new board members because we were
we'd lost some private sector
representation because of the impact of
the virus
and so four new members were suggesting
two on the board
three of whom have been able to join
today which is great uh we circulated
the details via email and
just wanted to sort of let everybody
know that effort responded favorably
and just wanted because we had to do it
and
via email just just to reiterate that
you know the board is happy to welcome
the new members
and just just to sort of have that point
for the notes and the minutes really
that you know
the board is comfortable with these
these new members i don't know if the
the new members wanted to
potentially introduce themselves to say
a little bit about
who they are on what they they can bring
to the the area and to
what their experiences other chairs are
okay
of course yes you agree and
shall i nominate people people to come
before you probably best if you suggest
in
in order okay so i'm just going to buy
order of my screen then so
um marie you're you're first on mine if
you
yeah hi thanks carl yes
hi um i'm marie cooper i'm ceo
of cb plus we have acquired
four businesses based in chesterfield on
the homewood industrial estate
and we've been working over the last
four years to consolidate them
um i've been working uh with jane
on a number of projects for um a few
years
involved in skills and developing the
young generation for future employment
skills for employability
um and and we're heavily involved in
lots of different projects and
and jim was the one that suggested we
get involved and help and
connect to this project and see where we
can go
it's quite exciting it's quite
interesting and you know we are local we
have a lot of local staff
and we want to recruit local where we
can it makes it makes a big difference
um so if we can help we can do that and
consolidate everything together it's
really exciting
i did involve uh nick holland as well at
um and unfortunately you know he became
a dad yesterday so that's why he's not
with us today but
they play a big part in the community as
well so i think together you know
we are connected together to a different
business network already so
hopefully we can bring that um
connection together as well with that
is that all right carl can't you say
anything that's great thank you and
anthony i know you prefer to be called
tony so it's
your next time asking if you could say a
bit about yourself yeah
no problem i'm tony walker i uh um
walk a higher on bridge street so we're
right at the heart of the
sort of regeneration area and
really my idea about being on the
committees or on the
on the board is that i want to protect
the local businesses
i went through the um last regeneration
when
tesco were built and i wasn't very happy
how things progressed then
so i just want to make sure that
everything is you know all the local
businesses
looked after as they should have been
done most of them have been there quite
a long time and
uh you know i really think that they
bring a lot of value to the area
so that's my uh my remit on it that's
great thank you
and then philip last but not
thank you good morning everybody i'm
philip webb um i wear two hats
um i've been in business about 31 years
of ex ibm as an engineer
one of my hats is all around
organizational change
so we deliver an awful lot of change to
businesses mostly
but also to public sector as well i've
been involved with the
derby city regeneration of pride park
many years ago
as the chamber president so i bring my
experiences there
the second hat and more recent is a
company called investors in community
where an online platform where business
meets third sector
and includes any not-for-profit in
schools by the way for the purpose of
facilitating volunteering gifting
and cash donations it's utterly free to
the charities
uh businesses subscribe it's been going
probably about two years now
we're headquartered in coney green
business center um so i offer you the
facilities of being able to
unify the two halves of our society in
terms of the
generation of the business sector and
also the
the not-for-profits and charity sectors
and we're working specifically around
people like wakefield town center derby
city town centres and others to
facilitate specific
improvements for example eradication of
rough sleeping
by coordinating the charitable sector
working with the donating sectors of
philanthropy and the businesses
so i've got a platform at our disposal
here look forward to working with you
all
and that's about me i think kyle thank
you thank you
okay thank you very much then if we move
swiftly on 2.6 on the agenda
the projects to be taken forward again
back to you carl
um as you know we submitted our
investment plan and we identified 10
projects
as part of that
ask plan the funding and there's 24.1
million
available to support those 10 projects
and however
we need the board to endorse that we
take forward those 10 projects
and to business case development which
is the next piece of work we'll be doing
because we have to submit on the 24th of
may
and to say that these are the projects
that we wish to take forward and we're
going to be
developing the business cases for this
next coming year
as as you can see from i mean you've got
experience of the investment plan you
know what the 10 projects are
they're also in your papers um but it's
just that
i suppose have that double check that
the board is happy for those 10 projects
to be taken forward
and that we go for the full 24.1 million
as part of that town investment plan
so as you'll see in the papers um the
the projects and the expected outcomes
are listed there
as i say we are all well aware of what
what they are
and so i'm not going to see us that we
go through them but maybe move straight
to the recommendations that the
clay cross down the board endorses the
10 projects
and we take them all forward for them
for business case development
okay carolyn yeah yeah we've put a lot
a lot of uh work into these uh into all
these ten projects
all equally important and critical to
the success of the whole town board and
i'm happy to second that yeah thank you
uh
lee rowley you have your panda yeah just
to absolutely confirm there's no change
to the configuration or number of
projects here we're basically just being
asked to approve what we've already
approved to go forward right i think
that's the first thing
okay thank you thank you
then move to accept that and move
forward and please
then moving on to any of the business
if i can't yeah i've got some peace on
your business so we have the working
groups as you're all aware and
we look as you've seen the closed
session we're talking about the business
case development and the consultants
so we'll be looking to get the invites
out for the working groups
and as for next week really so we'll get
those work groups together
and to start pulling together the piece
of work that the consultants will need
but also um helping bring forward the
stakeholders
and views to those pieces of work and
also we've got the communities and comms
working group which will be meeting more
regularly than
the other groups because we're keen that
the right message has been
um shared with the um
the town and the residents and the
businesses so as then
tony mentioned earlier you know we don't
want businesses to be
[Music]
fairly treated through this process and
we want them to be
um fully aware of all the information
that's that's available on our nls so
those working groups will be um in that
so as i say we're going out that's one
next week so um
keep an eye out for those in your diary
and if there's any work groups that you
wish to
join additional to the ones that you're
already a member of if you are a member
of those work groups
please do let me know and we'll see you
can get put on there i mean some of them
will be quite technical
and so some of the transport stuff is
very technical and
is sort of officer-led but by all means
you can attend but um
they're quite dry
yeah thank you very much carolyn you
have a point to raise
yeah yeah just to um remind um
in terms of the comments to make sure
that we're you know um as
we've got things to say we need to be
updating this board and probably local
councillors and the parish council
and anybody connected as soon as
possible then we can you know
i want to make sure that everyone's
thinking for the same hint sheet that
all the facts are there and that we
uh you know we're not getting good
people going off at tangents
um there's a lot of questions starting
to be raised about this and
we've got we've also got more questions
and answers at the moment but it will be
key to make sure that we keep
the the communications very tight and on
track
thank you any other comments for
any other business any more topics to
raise
not seeing any hands by me please
in representing private sector on this
board and i've seen many boards of the
same sort of
makeup can i be clear what the input is
required
and expected from the private sector
representation around this board
to make sure we have the right amount of
involvement and don't end up being a
tick box exercise frankly
yeah carl do you want to respond to that
yeah yeah yeah um
well as you know we have the working
groups um which
does a lot of the the work in terms of
um
those particular projects so all those
10 projects have a working group
attached
and some of the projects because they're
quite similar also
most together in terms of the built
environment so we would
strongly recommend that if you can and
have the time available that you would
join when i was working groups
and then you would be the voice for the
business sector
but also as um as karen crowley says
there's
we need to make sure the comms are um
accurate in terms of what's going on
i would ask that the board members the
private sector
get to join his working groups on the
comms group they share that
and that same message because what we
don't want is it just to be
a tick box exercise we actually want
this to be
embedded in the businesses and the
residents of playgrounds
so yeah if you can spare the time and
get involved with the working groups
that would be really appreciated
and it will help also bring a different
perspective to those working groups
because you can talk from
the private sector because your
understanding of the world is slightly
different to miners working in a local
authority
so um some of the stuff that we think
works in theory may not work or
translate into
business well so your experience would
certainly help
that'd be great carl thank you can we
can i have some kind of visibility or
what working groups
are there who's chairing them so i can
have the opportunity to get involved as
i would love to do
yeah of course what i'll do is then
we've circulated in the past the working
groups
and what we'll do is we'll recirculate
that uh we'll update it because then
some of the names have been built in now
so
we'll circulate that to all the board
and then if there's any work in groups
so
you feel a real desire that you could
actually add some value to that working
group
make sure that you include your money
thank you yeah
can i just add to that kyle sorry yeah
just picking up because i've seen the
working groups and there is a few that i
think we can add value to but you did
say that invites would be sent out so is
there specifics that you would want us
to get involved in and then we can
choose others
or is it okay so what you think we can
add to
well what we've done is based on what we
think
fits with the the skills and that that
we need so that's why i've identified
some
organizations so for instance some of
the art stuff you know johnson makes
sense for them to be in
other local arts and organizations but
if you feel actually that's one that we
could still add value to
because we wouldn't necessarily put your
organization down
as as a potential representation for
that that makes sense so
yeah what we'll do is we'll send out the
ones that it's a table really so what
organizations we've identified and then
if you wish to be added to that we can
include you on the additional ones and
we'll send out the invite for you
all the ones that we think would sort of
be appropriate for you
okay and would you be happy for us to
recommend anybody we think would add
value as well from our networks
absolutely the more people who can be
involved in their working group i mean
we don't want it so you know it's 100
people in it but
a strong working group where people are
going to have value
outside of this board i mean that's kind
of why we want you because you have
those links
within the community and the more people
involved
the better it's going to be in terms of
in being appropriate for
clay cross rather than any town any
place
because i think that's one thing that's
become clear because we're working with
jane on a low carbon project with
speakers for schools
and i was talking to dan hefferman as
well yesterday and it's quite clear that
we need to start communicating between
the
what's going on in the area and start
collaborating and joining the dots
because it's it's not always easy i
appreciate that but it's quite clear
that there's a lot more could be done if
we
if we can get them connections joined
together yeah absolutely
and it's so cheap but there's and
there's a lot of different groups out
there
working on broadly similar type things
so it's hard to map it all because
if you're not aware of the group you
don't want to duplicate the work that
they're doing but also you want to feed
in
to what they're doing or what they do to
feed into your group so if you're aware
of other groups by all means
let us know and we can try and map out
and so low carbon's a great example
because it's something that's quite key
in our entire investment plan
and it'd be useful if we tap into other
working groups or other pieces of work
that activity that's been done to sort
of
get that holistic approach rather than
just a a narrow focus that maybe misses
out on other stuff
do you want me to keep you posted on
things like that then because this is an
event that we're running
um it's a digital event where it's it's
specifically where
three schools in the area that james
lincoln to
to run a low cabin event that we're
facilitating a project for so
is it worth keeping you in luck for
things like that yeah absolutely
and jane has been talking to us about it
but yeah absolutely then
send it through and anything like that
is great
thank you very much carolyn yeah i think
i think um
as i said before i think i think we're
in this sort of halfway house where
you know we've got a plan of 10 projects
but very little detail
that's obviously because we've not uh
developed the business planning which is
which is the next 12 months we've got to
do
um so it's so it is about um controlling
the narrative a little bit what i think
i'm hoping carl is that uh the comms
group i know we're trying to build the
communication strategy is that they'd be
quite useful to have some kind of portal
that we could actually
uh or share queries questions so if
people getting
questions from businesses or um from
residents
um to the fact checking that we have
some way that
as a board can all actually um get under
some kind of pulse where we can actually
address these questions and make sure we
have the
correct answers
um if can't yeah um yeah we'll set
something up it might not necessarily be
a portal but it might be an
email address that you when you email so
we maybe i'll set up a clay cross town
deal board email
and myself or on a team will be able to
have access to that and pick up
um any queries to that if that
helps okay thank you very much
if there's no additional points then at
this point i'd like to
close the meeting to the public due to
exempt information and disclosure topics
so if we can end the youtube
broadcast now please
you